Throughout the years you have seen me
chop with many weird items
Some of you may know that in table tennis there are long pimple rubbers
that are usually used with a defensive playing style
When chopping, the pimples generate a great amount of underspin on topspin shots
But how difficult would it be to learn to play with a long pimple rubber
and switch your playing style from offensive to defensive?
Would it turn out to be a success
or a complete fail?
Okay so now I have a brand new table tennis racket
I have the long pimple on the red side
and this is gonna be extremely interesting to try this out
and see if I can do any chops with this
So here begins the one-year chopping challenge
In this video I'll share my thoughts on how changing my playing style has felt so far
One of the most difficult things in the beginning was the basic push
There you see the difficult part
trying to push with the long pimple
If it's a backspin it doesn't react the same way as a normal rubber
so you have to hit higher to make it on table
Pushing with the long pimple requires a different technique than pushing with an inverted rubber
so in the beginning pretty much all my long pimple pushes went in to the net
That just proves how important it is to get the basic push first
because if I can't get that on table
Then the points are very short
Try pushing a few
As you can see in this clip pushing with the long pimple
feels very different to pushing with the normal rubber
Yeah it's different
This is the real shot you need to practise
The most underrated and the most boring but probably the most important
Yeah exactly!
I also realized that pushing with the long pimple requires a longer stroke
because the ball doesn't grip to the pimples as it does to normal rubber
During the first weeks everything felt
really difficult
It was just very difficult to find any consistency with the chopping
And sometimes having the pimple rubber completely messed me up
What am I doing?
That was a block!
So used to blocking it
And as you can see here
having to twiddle the racket was another thing that I wasn’t used to
But at the same time, I had never before even tried playing with long pips
so it was also very interesting and a lot of fun to try it out!
When I eventually started to get a bit of feeling for the chopping
the next problem was that the chops were often too high
So high!
So it became very easy for Otto to just hit hard
and win the point.
So the thing I have to learn is to try to keep the chops lower above the net
and also place them better to make
it more difficult for the opponent
Another thing that is important to
remember is that being a chopper
means that you have to be patient
This is something that is really difficult to keep in mind
since I've been playing with an offensive playing style basically my whole life
before these two months
As an offensive player you want to be in control of the game
and make the shots yourself
But as a chopper you are doing pretty much the opposite
just trying to return the ball on table and waiting for the opponent to make errors
I also feel like I don't yet have the consistency to get so many chops on table in a row
so I often think that it's more likely for me to get a point
by trying to counter attack the topspin rather than chop it
But if I wan't to improve this style
I have to start finding the confidence in my chops
Being a chopper, the movement is also very important
Here is maybe the most challenging part
that being able to move fast from here to here
to be able to get the long and the fast shot
So a lot of good footwork is required
which I don't have yet
So I've been practicing my chops with regular exercises for a while now
and tried to focus on the technique and
the basics
Let's see if I can apply anything of it in a real match
It's going to be interesting to see the
difference with this set
compared to like after one year
This is probably gonna be horrible
Here you can clearly see the problem
with the pushing
As you can see in this one game match,
everything becomes much more difficult when you don’t know where the ball is coming
You don’t really know what to do with the pimple, where to move and when to go for an attack
It’s just more difficult than in regular exercises
and also shows why you should do irregular exercises in training.
So in short, you could say that it’s been a quite challenging journey this far
and I’ve already several times, especially after playing some matches,
wanted to change back to an inverted rubber.
It’s sometimes hard to remember that it takes a lot of time and practice to learn a new playing style
and reach even the same level that you had with the previous playing style
It’s a long process and requires much more training
Don't return it!
Why do you hit it straight to my racket
My fault yeah sorry
But I also have to say that its been really exciting to try a new aspect of the sport
and get to understand choppers better
I think it’s a very cool and fun playing style when you get better at it
so I’ll keep on fighting and try to improve more.
I call it the dynamite!
The dynamite shot!
Dynamite!